au milieu des montagnes des asturies au
creux d'une vaste valait 1 roi alphonse
2 10 le chaste décida au viiie siècle de
bâtir sa capitale non il a régné ici
pendant 50 ans et il a fait construire
l'église de sainte hierso la cathédrale
c'était un roi bâtisseur
aujourd'hui oviedo abrite l'un des plus
beaux centres historiques d'espagne
treize siècles d'histoire catholique
ininterrompue
tard il se rétablit a été réalisée entre
1502 et 1506 1 au xvième siècle
c'est de style gothique flamboyant et
c'est une description des évangiles sur
une seule page et non à paris
autour de la cathédrale
monastère cloître et couvents se
succèdent à oviedo beaucoup de choses
tournent autour de la religion des plus
classiques aux plus inattendues
comme vous voyez je suis un curé j'adore
tout ce qui est religieux les augustins
les sainte-thérèse et regardez mon père
on a aussi des réduite
péché par gourmandise
rien de plus facile à oviedo
sous les halles du marché c'est toute la
région qui offre ses plus beaux produite
ses spécialités
ça c'est de la fab adha il ya des fèves
du chorizo du boudin et du lard
à côté du cassoulet asturiens voici le
caillou un fromage de tête locale
non il n'ya pas un pet de grâce et que
de la gélatine
dans les ruelles autour du
marché1 sont surpris
de la cornemuse
les asturiens serait-il cousins des
bretons
la réponse est oui ils sont tous les
deux cents
l'art et st gall ça c'est la cornemuse
asturienne elle ressemble un peu à celle
que vous avez en france mais elle a
quelques caractéristiques locales
et les similitudes ne s'arrêtent pas là
oviedo compte plus de 50 cidrerie
boissons régionales le cidre se sert
avec style
parfois que le cidre explose dans le
vert que ça fasse de la mousse comme ça
les arômes remonte
à oviedo
le cidre se voit traditionnellement
cul-sec
moitié celte moitié ibérique oviedo
assume fièrement ses différences